[Musique]
en direct du canada en direct de
montréal alors avancer maintenant de
l'est du pays
nous avons cinq fuseaux horaires et
demie 1 1 c'est bien mon à revendre il
est 11h15 heure de montréal ici même en
studio
nous avons des collègues de la section
française de radio-canada international
marie jobin qui se joint à notre équipe
et bonjour maryse dangereux stéphane
elle est complètement à l'autre bout du
studio et au milieu du studio se trouve
à l'isf chantal qu'on va voir dans
quelques instants en dévoile de la joie
là bonjour belles couleurs fantastiques
ou leur mère étant sentez-vous un la
menace d'armes
on va parler de ça en début d'émission
c'est incontournable
il faut faire ce qu'on appelle notre
travail de vous informer du climat ou à
tout le moins du climat l'atmosphère ici
qui règne au canada ou dans certaines
parties du pays
on a autour de 160 cas de personnes qui
maintenant sont officiellement infectées
par le virus a le corps aux virus ou
cocorosie voilà mon latin à écouter je
suis un petit peu d il ya un mot en
anglais pour ce je vous le donnerai pas
déjà un petit peu déséquilibré
aujourd'hui par le fait qu' on avait
prévu une émission sur un certains
thèmes ce qu'on va faire un peu plus
tard mais également il faut faire place
à cette question qui préoccupe les
canadiens est-ce que je vais être
infecté est ce que mes proches vont être
infectées
est-ce que je vais survivre tout le
monde se pose la question et vous
remarquerez ici qui est un peu plus de
distance entre nous sommes pratiquement
où il faudrait que l'écran soit plus
grand encore pour la peau de ces trois
pieds et demi pour les choses s'étaient
passées grains noirs dans la belle salle
à distanciation sociale et l'habitation
sion sion seul c'est aussi le phénomène
d'une poste présentée en public d'éviter
les grands rassemblements et on en est
là qu est ce qui a été annulée cette
semaine marie josèphe niveau des de
montréal par exemple un nom unique par
la ville de montréal est presque tous
les événements culturels où il n'y a
plus de 250 personnes qui se rassemblent
au fait
à l'échelle des amériques pour le sport
oublié seul je regarde les gants régime
vous aurez pas de match en direct il va
rien se passer
que ce soit dans la ligue nationale la
nba qui sont annulés côté des jeunes
et là je pense que c'est au niveau des
écoles quand les gens entendent dire que
les écoles doivent rester fermés ou
resteront fermés à 100 heures the social
du gouvernement du ministère d'éducation
mais qu'elle prenne elle-même la
décision il ya comme un mouvement
panique commence véritablement à
s'installer les 10 les gens disent aimer
mon enfant reste à la maison
qu'est-ce que je le ferai dans les
écoles il ya des enfants qui ont voyagé
avec leurs parents durant ce match qui
était pour certains en europe et même en
italie
donc c'est pour cette raison que la
commission scolaire ne prennent pas de
et du russe est ce qu'on veut éviter ils
nous disent les autorités de santé c'est
cette fameuse courbe que peut-être que
vous avez vus à la télé où on veut
aplanir la courbe se comptent pas par un
pic
tout à fait c'est ce qu'a dit le
directeur planning contrôler tout à fait
des graves week dans la population
on peut être assez automatiques ou avant
dès septembre neiger mais quand même
être contaminés que tout le problème
c'est qu'on passe aux autres il ya des
gens qui sont plus généreux tout à fait
écouter légèrement faire la part des
choses il ya des choses qu'on doit veut
surveiller lorsqu'il ya une communion
bien épidémie dans ce cas c'est une
pandémie c'est le taux de communication
de la maladie cnam terme très sain ce
fait pour soi mais si je suis gelé je
vais le communiqué en moyenne à combien
de personnes
c'est une personne dans le cas de ceux
coronavirus dans le cas de la
tuberculose je pense que c ou c 12
autour de ces très élevé c'est très très
communicatif civile ce virus peut on se
rappelle des sanatoriums qu'envoyait à
une époque georges qui n'a pas de
médicaments
donc il ya des maladies qui se
communique plus que d'autres il ya aussi
un autre aspect c'est mortalité et voilà
tout survie moi je suis positif
et puis à quel âge on est le plus
susceptible d'avoir des troubles majeurs
et on sait que c'est 80 % des gens qui
s'en tire relativement bien avec des
symptômes mineurs mais comme vous êtes
un âge avancé on parlais tantôt de des
personnes âgées de 60 ans et plus qui
devrait vraiment faire attention et peu
après les recommandations et l'amicale
savoir éviter de rendre visite aux
personnes âgées dans nos ch et celle des
donc c'est vraiment des précautions
individuelle qu'il faut prendre pour
éviter la propagation de ce virus
il ya des paradoxes dans tout ça je veux
parler du phénomène de la panique
comment il se fait que l'être humain est
sujet à la panique son ca a été jugé
comme phénomène n'est pas pas on n'est
pas fous la chose qui est normal à peine
intéressé c'est l'instinct de la janvier
il ya des gens qui sont déjà anxieux en
partant alors quand arrive une situation
comme celle ci
les gens deviennent anxiogène on essaie
d'avoir le contrôle sur quelqu'un chez
ça ça va très rapidement j'aurais conter
une histoire mais j'apporte fière
d'aider des choses à ma mère qui était
tombé malade récemment donc elle veut
préfère ne pas sortir et elle
m'accueille la maison avec un masque aux
gt comme m'avait rien dit à laquelle son
fils avec ma seule la lgv est enlevée en
disant peut-être que j'exagère mais je
me lave les mains une fois rentrée chez
elle sa première chose que je suis en
baisse et cesser les bonnes manières
c'est ça aujourd'hui c'est également
penser à cette a7 maire de laval qui est
allé accueillir sa fille à l'aéroport il
ya quelque deux jours et qui a été
obligé de louer une petite maison pour
la maintenir en confinement le temps de
voir si elle n'est pas touché par le
virus
place au commerce maintenant puisque
c'est un aspect important de cette crise
ce qui se passe à la bourse bien sûr et
ce qui se passe dans les magasins les
magasins
c'est vraiment la ruée vers les denrées
de première nécessité
le papier toilette je peux pas vous le
vent il comprendrait bien ce sera un
conflit d'intérêt surtout que ça viendra
tout canada je pourrais facilement vous
le cd jeux comme jamais
touché je vous passe la tension mais à
l'arrivée un papier de toilette
c'est quand même extraordinaire ces
histoires c'est un phénomène incroyable
il y en a qui vont se procurer des
tonnes et des tonnes de boue je sais pas
moi même à la plage mais dirigeants
devraient aussi se préoccuper de la
nourriture parce qu'avant la de gucht
aviez toilettes il faut manger de la
série qu'on a ce qu'il faut à la maison
écoutez moi j'ai hâte l'émission se
termine pour que j'allais faire mon show
p nick schuyler elles ont besoin de ma
voiture j'ai aussi apparemment il faut y
aller tôt le matin à ce que les gens
achètent tellement fait quand même là je
suis la fille apparemment très très
longue dans certains d'entre eux
il faut attendre deux heures de temps
pour payer pour passer à l'action
les viandes apparemment si vous trouvez
dans le secteur des viandes la boucherie
y est je peux raconter des histoires
personnelles ici mais j'en ai on a envie
plusieurs ce matin en promenade puis il
manque de poulet ou les étages un
article pour aujourd'hui prévoir sur le
site
à propos de ça et on sait de deux
experts leur transmettant quand vous a
mis la table pour vous parler d'un quoi
ça ressemble ce sentiment de panique de
j'appellerais ça de l'effervescence moi
je les sens si la première fois sur une
main hier après midi c'est vraiment un
branle bas général hier après-midi avant
son jeu derrière j'ai fait un petit peu
fatigué fatigué un bon québécois tanné
de parler du coronavirus monza mais
c'est ma job c'est mon travail
d'informer les gens je pas le choix si
c'est ça le sujet le plus important est
là vous avez encore moins de choix ben
oui je raconte est ce que c'est le
problème des médias dans une situation
où les gens prennent panique encore il
faut informer les gens étaient et il
faut s'assurer de donner la bonne
information aux gens voilà alors sur
plus d'informations c'est aussi un
problème pour moi contribuer à cette
panique c'est à vous avez jusqu'au au
chapeau de morale je vous racontais le
point de vue ici d'un spécialiste qui
s'appelle sylvain de louvain si cool
sociologue et maître de conférences à
l'université de rennes en france la
france qui elle-même a des problèmes
tout à fait actuellement et on lui a
posé la question
l'information délivrée au public par les
médias peut-elle être aussi un vecteur
de la panique collective à ce qu'on
participe à ça évidemment la réponse est
oui et il expliqué
c'est un cercle vicieux à partir du
moment où une telle épidémie est en
train d'approcher forcément les
journalistes vont l'évoquer c'est bien
tout est clair à partir du moment où ils
l'évoquent qu'il la rendre plus
accessible au grand public à partir du
moment où grand public et plus au
courant il devient plus intéressés donc
les journées ce travail travaillent plus
pour les informer encore davantage etc
et je ne pense pas que dit il que les
journées se crée la panique comme les
citoyens les journées se sont pris dans
un mouvement d'ensemble face à une
épidémie et cherche à se rassurer eux
mêmes c'est à dire à comprendre ce qui
se passe et pour se rassurer monsieur ou
madame tout le monde va essayer d'aller
lui-même web même chercher des
informations à droite et à gauche des
fois au mauvais poste pour ne pas les
citer
les journées ils vont faire leur métier
d'information en principe selon le type
de média de manière plus ou moins
objectives mais toujours quand même avec
une méthodologie professionnels du
journalisme
ils vont faire leur travail la valve et
l'habitat en france donc il n'a pas le
problème de certains médias aux états
unis qui n'ont que la version du
président ah oui et et je dirais qu avec
l'instantanéité des médias d'aujourd'hui
goût ou tout le monde s'envoie des
petits messages par twitter et autres
atouts gong bon qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors voilà une alerte annonce assez
c'est une haine c'est écouter cet sujet
d'une précédente édition c'est taisez
vous voilà c'est une arnaque
on a parlé dans une précédente mission
vous pouvez aller sur notre site web
voir ça et ce téléphone qui viennent
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui s'appelle du
ministère du revenu du canada
voilà howie alloué ccc ce numéro c'est
fall ces fameux voleurs de données
des fois il parle en anglais
des fois il parle en français mais le
[ __ ] [ __ ] c'est un anglais puis
ensuite avec voire chinois qui détient
là on comprend que l'on vise davantage
la personne qui vient d'émigrer au
canada
ce 1 millions canadiens d'origine
chinoise et le mot d'ordre c'est quoi
une retournée mais en palabres et voilà
on va là la barre ou été supprimé le
numéro de téléphone
mais en ce qu'ils inventent un nouveau
numéro de l'avenir surya rejetant dans
le dos et puis moi j'ai eu tous les
jours un nouveau numéro
alors ça le sujet c'est aujourd'hui un
peu le monde de la panique mais aussi le
fait que on avait bien en parler
aujourd'hui mais heureusement moi j'ai
passé ma semaine a essayé de préparer
une prochaine émission qui devait porter
sur plusieurs sujets à la fois notamment
ce qui se passe à la bourse donc si vous
avez des questions pour nous c'est un
auditeur en france qui m'a posé la
question cette semaine est ce que vous
ne contribuez pas vous même il nous
promettait pas du doigt un merci mais
vous les médias à ce mouvement panique
et j'ai dit je veux faire de la
recherche
et il lui en retour m'envoyer
d'information ce que je viens de vous
donner c'est une partie de l'information
que la pression qu'il nous a communiquée
donc ça fonctionne dans les deux sens
c'est mieux quand ça fonctionne dans les
deux sens a besoin de sang je pense
plutôt que un chacun dans sa tour
d'ivoire en train d'essayer de deviner
voilà comment comment on va faire les
choses voilà pour aujourd'hui
donc je vous libère tout de suite et
puis vérifie c'est terminé on se
passerait bien sûr bien sûr
est-ce que ça commence tout de suite ça
commence tout de suite on va faire une
version écourtée de notre voilà notre
émission aujourd'hui alors le thème de
l'émission officiellement aujourd'hui
porte sur quoi nous allons vous
présenter cette eau est ce que je vous
ai présenté je vous êtes de présenter
une vidéo sur les mouvements les gens
qui achetaient des choses en maman n'ont
pas encore oublié ça non je veux pas
contribuer au mouvement
oui ok au canada alors voici maintenant
la vidéo numéro 5 images
quoi qu'est ce qu'il dit c'est parce
qu'il ya déjà une question à l'écran
qu'on peut voir quelle est la population
d'abidjan nord s'il vous plaît vous
mettez des questions et je suis sûr que
madame alors à la réponse ben abidjan
allez-y c'est sûr parce qu'en afrique
c'est pas belle et si vous vous
connaissez pas juger l'émission bravo
non non tu mais vous avez la question on
va y aller vers la question maintenant
d'accord même si vous connaissez pas le
sujet la population d'abidjan à la
vision c'est la capitale j'ai la
question sur tf1 on peut rien vous avez
[Musique]
la population d'abidjan 2,2 millions ou
est ce que ces bébés 4,4 millions reste
que ces ses 8,8 millions mais
abidjan c'est quand même une grande
ville c'est une ville où se brassent pas
mal d'affaires en afrique de l'ouest et
vous déjà allé abidjan non j'ai survolé
abidjan oui on a oui je dirais entre
vienne 4 millions
parce que je voudrais vous à 20 mille
bêtes d'altitude là c'est une salaire
d'une grosse galère d'une grosse ville
où on veut dire hé bé bé oui mais moi je
disais tente requêtes et deux parce que
je me dis je ne sais pas si autant de
gens que par exemple la capitale du
sénégal
alors moi je vais aller avec à pied ne
convient dans la capitale syrienne
je ne sais pas me fixer quiberon donc
appel à moi ok alors il vous reste à
huit secondes encore pour y ajuster
votre réponse belge je reste avec ma
réponse b b d'accord pour aller c'est
plus mal justement je vais respecter à a
c'est très bien alors une d'entre vous
avez perdu vos verres ball voilà c'est
parce qu'elle avait dit aux jeux pas
trop gourmands c'est pas mon pays je
vais du cameroun est finalement ben je
sais que généralement dans ces grandes
métropoles africaines
il ya beaucoup de gens mais maintenant
on va dépasser 6 millions c'est parce
que la population générale c'est autour
de 5 millions ou 17 millions c'est ça
donc il serait totalement aberrant qu'on
des 8 millions juste à abidjan et le
reste du pays qu'est ce qu'on en fait
que ces choses m'ont chargé avec les
taux de natalité très très drôle
d'alliance que kinshasa
ça va être la plus grande ville
africaine à part le caër bien sûr si
quelques années et addis abeba aussi ah
oui en étions il ya mama des choses qui
se passe en ce moment
enfin il ya comme un nouveau monde qui
se créent dans ce pays là c'est un pays
où poussent pas mal d'immeubles où il ya
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs étrangers qui
viennent signer des contrats avec des
partenaires locaux
tu sais pas si vous avez suivi le
documentaire d'hasebe un sol dur dur il
est inexact
la fatigue un travail super intéressant
sur trame il est sur son pays je trouve
que c'est son pays d'origine tout à la
base alors on va aller vers la côte
d'ivoire puisque vous
à mener et voici vidéo cinq images
d'enfants notre sujet c'est la côte
d'ivoire c'est qu'il ya quelque chose
qui se passe là bas il ya le président
ouattara qui sera pas candidat à la
prochaine élection si ça c'est pas
politique c'est pas politique n'est pas
politique
alors on regarde ces cinq images janvier
vous en faites pas là voila voila c'est
pour situer la côte d'ivoire pour tout
le monde d'accord oui à l'ouest c'est en
afrique de l'ouest
un peu proche de l'océan atlantique cara
tigana ridjali sur la grotte élevé du
désert oui du désert bien sûr c'est sûr
qu'on a imaginé robot 4 dans ces villes
là on a toujours le nom bien qu'ils
avaient un indice important
massa le marché des arts et culture
bravo félicitations je suis bien content
alors ça se termine demain et dans cette
édition là le canada est à l'honneur au
marché disant sur la tête d'abidjan on
devait faire une entrevue avec le
responsable du conseil canadien de la
culture qui a dû se désister pour une
raison mystérieuse au dernier moment de
façon tout à fait mystérieux josy c'est
un véritable mystère mais on n'en fera
pas une soupe mais on devait aussi je
paraisse que je vérifie avec le service
tts qu'on a quelqu'un en côte d'ivoire
abidjan qu à qui on pourrait parler au
téléphone vous on me dit quand des
problèmes techniques et je doute que on
peut se résoudre à faire mais c'est
quand même bien parce que vous êtes là
et nous avons des images de la masa et
puis allez voir ça ça et moi j'ai été
impressionné on va regarder la vidéo
numéro 2 c'est le commanditaire orageux
téléphone orange c'est bien sûr je sais
c'est qu'ils ont c'est très important à
la fri pirateurs économique téléphonique
en afrique est un acteur européen
c'est un acteur européen
mais en afrique il ya beaucoup de
concurrents et a notamment
mtn qui est sud africain je crois d'un
quai qui opère également un afrique de
l'ouest et en afrique centrale je pense
que de la cdc des compagnies qui ont
totalement démocratisé l'accès aux
téléphones mobiles dans certains pays
d'afrique
donc là c'est vraiment les images du
marché oui les spectacles avec des
spectacles alors c'est comme peu à
montréal
c'est pas que dans un endroit précis où
il a dansé ça on s'amuse une grosse
affaire j'ai été très surpris puis je
vais vous montrer la vidéo numéro 3 ou
est-ce qu orange devrait être comme une
espèce de commanditaires pour cet
événement
et puis c'est un événement très couru
parce qu'on a pas mal d'artistes qui
viennent d'horizons divers et un de
différents pays d'afrique
bon disons oui c'est un pays francophone
mais n'oublions pas qu'en afrique qui a
plusieurs langues aussi des langues
locales donc naturellement les artistes
vont devoir également s'exprimer dans
leur langue régionale ou locale
c'est un peu la côte d'ivoire là c'est
la onzième édition je me souviens bien
moi je me souviens est un petit garçon
j'écoutais à l'heure du midi
parce qu'on appellera un radio romands
qui venait de la côte d' ivoire
d'abidjan et c'était très côté parce
qu'abidjan avait la réputation sur mon
vieux de vingt années de plus ce n'est
quand même la réputation des gens à ce
moment là d'être un centre de la culture
du rayonnement culturel des productions
je sais pas si ça c'est vous les envies
au cameroun comme nous est pas dupe et
il a fait un bond ou henry
mais est ce qu'une compétition le
cameroun et la côte d'ivoire à ce sujet
mais je ne dirais pas qu'il ya une
compétition il ya comme une espèce de
complémentarité entre ces pays là parce
que des fois il ya le cameroun qui va
accueillir certains des éditions de
rencontres culturelles
il ya également une ville au sénégal sur
la côte atlantique
je crois c'est la ville de saint louis
sénégal qui est une ville très très
culturel aussi et a également des
marchés des marchés des arts et du
spectacle qui se déroule sur une base
annuelle ou bien mieux je sais pas moi
sur dans cette ville-là etc des
événements qui brave qui attire pas mal
pas mal d'artistes des artistes qui
viennent de la france de plusieurs pays
d'afrique et même de l'afrique du sud
je sais pas si vous connaissez celle du
sénat j habitais madame vacances bien
oui je connais tous - est-ce que c'est
un bord de mer
oui oui ce soir c'est un banc demain
c'est vraiment au bord de l'océan
moi je me rappelle de la plage de petro
base
et oui est ce que vous connaissez
l'explorateur français mermoz s'est vu
à l'école j'étais pas très bon écoutez
c'est pas une affaire d'être bon mais je
sais que à saint louis du sénégal il ya
un hôtel les porte son nom l'hôtel
mermoz oui oui et puis c'est comme une
espèce
je veux dire dommage que la ville a
voulu rendre à cet homme qui a traversé
l'océan
on peut venir à la déco à la rencontre
des populations locales
c'est une ville extrêmement particulière
au niveau son architecture tout à fait
je ne savais pas et enfin mais après bon
j'apprends j'ai vu des mêmes un
documentaire attention l'histoire
saint louis du sénégal a été la capitale
de toute l'afrique occidentale
francophone un moment donné donc avec la
présence française
naturellement à cette époque là c'était
vraiment à celui que toutes les
décisions régionales s'est prêtée prise
avant avant les années
l'indépendance donc il ya un port assez
important dans cette affaire dans cette
région et moi également vous parliez
tantôt des architectures ce qui m'a
marqué c'est vraiment les locaux du
gouverneur que le gouverneur de cette
région là et c'est un immeuble
centenaire je crois et qui est toujours
debout très très fier c'est qu'elle
sorte d'architecturé ça ça rappelle un
peu les anciens bâtiments français
oui c'est un peu le style comme on dit
simplement coloniale oui le style
colonial un peu modernisé avec le temps
parce que la façade et un peu comme
rénové est ce que vous êtes c'est vrai
au niveau d'une rénovation des maisons
c'est des vieilles façades pour nous
relever toutes les tout l'intérieur
d'affaires c'est le jeu vous pensez que
vous êtes dans une vieille ville qui est
en train de tomber mais découpés et
comme le dit si bien si bien celle du
sénégal rappelle certaines vieilles
villes françaises comme montpellier
c'est vrai que oui parce que au niveau
de l'architecturé et les français qui
ont bâti cette ville et du coup il ya
une ressemblance c'est vrai moi quasi
similaire nous fait voyager sur plus en
2010 il ya beaucoup de la couvrir
vous êtes prêt pour le deuxième
génération ça fait de la peine de voir
vous avez quelqu'un d'entre vous voulez
faire parce que là on a une experte
monsieur on va continuer à parler de
cette belle grande ville de 4,4 millions
d'habitants d'abidjan d'accord comme si
on était d'accord
alors voici jeudi la bellevilloise
parler du pays un peu là il faudrait
quand même découvrir un peu plus sa côte
d'ivoire comment comme les noms suivants
attécoubé cocody
behague au mas corrie et yopougon
est ce que ce sont des noms de villes de
côte d'ivoire est ce que ce sont des
noms d'artistes de côte d'ivoire qui ont
participé par exemple à la massage
japonais par exemple yopougon est une
ville en ville très célèbre
c'est un bon été et j'irai avec la
réponse vous iriez avec à marisa ce que
ce sont cocody également oui j'ai
entendu parler de cocody est ce que ce
serait céder noms de politiciens de côte
d'ivoire maryse où aucune de ces
réponses déjà n'ai pas parlé de déchets
pas pourquoi dont je n'avais pas parlé
de b&b des noms d'artistes de côté pour
moi c'est vraiment un
a parce que là dedans il ya au moins
deux villes oui c'est bon de vienne et
puis c'est cocody ok mais c'est plus
qu'un an de ville portent les antennes 8
secondes
non vous arrêtez votre char
nécessairement moi ça je vais me ranger
avec madame madame heather moyse est là
parce que là dedans on à yopougon et
cocody qui sont des noms du ville madame
mesdames regarder la réponse c'est
pourquoi ce deuxième temps c'était
aucune de ces répond mais ça veut dire
que vous avez introduit des noms alors
on se fait une idée née ville angérien
introduit moi je n'ai fait que
sélectionné parce que cocody c'est une
ville web yopougon également oui ce sont
des communes à des communes des communes
il faut avoir le terme ce sont des
produits religion ok d'accord c'est tous
les présidents alors comme une session
pourtant c'est à dire quartier nous
c'était simplement une idée madame
d'abel des écoles et des hôpitaux ça je
m'en souviens se laisse course aviez
l'habitude de vous déplacer en
transports en commun d'écouter cet
amusant parce que mais pas celle du
travail et pendant des autobus bariolés
donc en couleur où il sait quelque chose
ah non en vélo j'étais sur la fourche du
vélo de mon père parce que j'étais tout
petit face comme ça je me transportait
je ne transportait pas moi vers l'est
oui je me faisais transport part que
cette sévère vélo ou en marche est parce
qu on n'habitait pas loin du
centre-ville en fait l'animal en
centre-ville vraiment le sénat
un peu étalée sur des morceaux ici là
c'était pas loin de la bibliothèque
parce qu'on y allait souvent à pied pour
aller chercher les albums de tintin
hockey se souviendra famille avait misé
boucherie bien amusant puis on va
toujours un sont tellement jeunes
jusqu'à l'âge de 6 ans madame me
souviens de sa le fil sa pop art que
cette chose sérieuse avait perdu tout
nouveau point d'être un point d'une
deuxième on y va pour le troisième jeu
50 boules à perdre on va redescendre 50
bounaceur à perdre
je sais qu'il ya du vin lisez la
question pour tout le monde à la maison
de trappes haut de la côte d'ivoire
ressemble à quoi orange blanc vert bleu
jaune rouge rouge jaune vert oui vert
jaune rouge d'accord basique qui est
classé qui a dû ya du vert or je pense
et c'est bien bonne déduction et a dû
aménager duverne à l'étroit dans trois
réponses à ces biens reese ça vous à
être ça l'est du verre blanc ouais
oh je sais pas trop mais il ya du jaune
donc on peut éliminer peuple bleu le
jaune moi je vais vous aider un peu mais
quand même faut pas que vous partiez
avec zéro orange bon mais la chine a mis
en avant le verbe ordina les accueils du
festival de massacrer comme en ce moment
là dedans je vais rouge et jaune c'est
le campo la secte ouvert où je notais
c'est dans l'autre c'est bien dans les
bandes verticales rouges adverse c'est
donc pas votre drapeau c'est un c'est le
drapeau d'un autre pays rouges
on arrête les choix square est j'ai fait
baisser écouter maryse b b comme bernard
pas trop c'est mal parti
2 c'était à on regarde la bonne réponse
montrouge ok alors ch planches blanc vin
alors j'avais dû promettre mais je pense
à toutes ces rumeurs
oui alors les amis vous est pris avec
eux on va maintenant parisse attention
grande visite ici à radio canada
international en direct abidjan en côte
d'ivoire
sidibé de maféré qui est un journaliste
et un producteur radio là bas et je
pense qu'il est source car être chose
est certaine on peut lui parler
alors ces 10 b bonjour est ce que vous
nous voyez en voilà je pourrais très
bien je vois de la meinau beau lescar
feliz dynamique fantastique
écoutez on est fier de vous avoir avec
nous même si le temps est un peu plus
court la réponse à laquelle on n'a pas
question on a posé la question à
laquelle en a pas c'est qu'elle faisait
le canada au massa et comment vous
l'avez souligné c'était le pays en
donnant le pays qui était l'invité
d'honneur
j'ai pas de réponse quelle est votre
réponse la réponse est simple canada
était à ce massacre est représenté avec
un sens plus de 120 artistes et pour
essayer de créer un pont culturel entre
le canada et l'afrique
ça a été une grande réussite est ici et
nous avons eu à les entretiens avec des
artistes canadiens et villate idée de
penny naturellement avec les
responsables naturellement on va parler
de monsieur six morts bo qui est le
responsable du conseil des arts du
canada qui a contribué aussi à cette
visibilité de la des arts du canada
assume à sa 11e édition du matin dites
moi vous vous avez parlé d'un certain
nombre d'artistes vous avez dit ça
rapidement c'était plus de seins donc
c'était des artistes qui venaient de sks
que vous il ya des noms que vous avez
retenu pour nous qu'on connaîtra
peut-être même des gens qui sont qui
sont sortis un people en dix anciens
c'est bien ça on peut parler par exemple
baptiste comme une artiste grave qui
fait des graffitis michael michel qui
est encore comptes a rien qui a fait du
graffiti le mur du palais de la culture
où est le siège du matin on peut citer
aussi baignoire il ya au davidson qui
est un conteur et qui lui à travers ses
contes 10 culture qu'on a essayé de
faire voyager l'esprit des spectateurs
qui sont arrivés à ce matin à travers la
culture canadienne
au delà des artistes nous pourrons citer
aussi des personnalités kanak et ils
sont sept délégations
je parlais tantôt du sim ont beau lui et
le président du conseil des arts et à la
date et à travers des interviews qu'ils
nous ont accordée par exemple monsieur
simon demande une quittons la diplomatie
qui nous quittons la diplomatie
économique et politique où aller vers la
diplomatie culturelle labidi quoi la
diplomatie culturelle c'est de créer un
fonds des changes entre les artistes du
sud du nord ont essayé de monter des
programmes qui peuvent aider les
diplomates à pouvoir régler les
questions de solidarité du partage du
coup ils ont libéré oui on se préoccupe
étant de savoir est ce que la
programmation de ce matin là c'est
uniquement en français est ce que c'est
uniquement les artistes de pays
francophones qui sont conviés à ce
marché
non évidemment le marché des spectacles
toutes les langues
tous sont conviés on a des artistes qui
nous arrive du canard aussi du nigeria
de l'afrique du sud qui ont fait les
performances à suez la scène du massage
mais il faut dire que le pourcentage des
pays comprenait assez élevé compte tenu
que ici le français
la langue la plus parlée je suis curieux
de savoir vous êtes un journée faut le
signaler
je vous connais je travaille avec vous
dans le passé et je pense il ya but not
dix ans et puis on se souvient de vous à
radio canada international avec grand
respect et admiration pour la qualité de
travail je vous le dis en passant un
chien que tout le monde le sache et bien
je voudrais savoir
je pense que vous avez un lien
d'affection particulier pour les
canadiens au canada ce que vous pourriez
nous raconter quelque chose à ce sujet
la table moi j'étais très heureux de
retrouver cette symphonie de la langue
canadien quand le québécois d'esprit et
j'avais laissé pendant un an depuis 2000
que je n'avais pas retrouvé
c'était pour moi c'est un voyage dans
l'espace et en voyant ce dans la culture
et il faut dit le canada à se faire
remarquer positivement à cette ce rendez
vous du donner et du recevoir n'a été
aussi le positionnement du canada dans
le cas des déserts et moi au moins j'ai
pu faire les comptes a depuis fait des
contacts avec renouer des contacts avec
des médias je parle par exemple de télé
québec qui à travers son stand plaisir
de voyager les spectateurs à travers une
voie numérique j'ai dû rêver imaginaire
à travers des casques qui faisait du
pouvoir des comptes
n'hésitez pas des artistes canadiens
donc voir en somme une occasion de me
ressourcer encore avec le canada
il ya combien de canadiens je suis pas
si jamais ces chiffres là comme ça au
cas où encore dit ouah c'est quand même
un des pays comme le sénégal ou qu'elle
vers lequel le canada
beaucoup d'affection mais ce que vous
avez une idée du nombre de deux comment
on appelle ça des expatriés non des
coopérants voilà des coupures à canadien
des coopérants je ne pourrais pas vous
donner un exemple
ce qui est sûr je vous ai dit nous avons
eu 20 ans prêté avec son excellence
madame julie chandail hier à l'ambassade
du canada ou voir l'importance pourquoi
est ce que le canada facilité à ses
pieds passés pts et l'invitation de la
côte d'ivoire mais dans son antre
étienne dano nouveau marqué que la
petite communauté où ce nom les
ressortissants canadiens qui étaient ici
et sont passés assez nombreux mais tu as
même pour ceux qui sont revenus en côte
d'ivoire sont d'origine ivoirienne mais
qui sont revenus encore du bois qui sont
assez ferme assez acceptable et se
retrouve à travers cette culture des
retrouve à travers ce matin pour
échanger oui je me demandais quelle
sorte des changes pourrait se faire
entre des artistes canadiens
peut-être que vous avez vu la banque
pour y découvrir ici avec des artistes
de la côte d'ivoire qui s'offre des
changes pourrait avoir lieu selon vous
entre des artistes ivoiriens et des
artistes canadiens
par exemple quand je prends par exemple
la boucle en b mal malika qui fait du
dollar a eu des échanges des passages
politique quand le canada a organisé
cette soirée d'échangés du réseautage
on se demandait 4 qui peut avoir cette
question était vraiment la bienvenue au
club qui vous pouvez avoir comme qui
change mais on se retrouve que deux
artistes peuvent se retrouver et essaie
d'établir un projet culturel à savoir
celui du canada pourrait venir en côte
d'ivoire et changer sa culture échanger
partager et apprendre la culture de
l'autre naze l atelier artistique et a
peint après le séjour en côte d'ivoire
des troupes embarquées pour le canada
pour expérimenter aussi cette culture
canadienne au delà de tout ce que
pouvais peut apporter
nous pensons que s'il existe cette
plateforme des changes de collaboration
les artistes dans leur intelligence
pourront mettre des projets innovants
sur place pour permettre aux cultures de
se connaître et avoir cette facilité de
la voix le dialogue des cultures entre
les différentes communautés
alors le magasin est rendu à 111e
édition est en creux se défend de
parents vous avez été de toutes ses
éditions là en terme de retombées et de
bilan c'est quoi vraiment les retombées
pour la ville pour abidjan pour abidjan
et vous avez à vos remboursements sur
l'espace et des femmes vendeuses qui ont
l'occasion pendant le matin d'installer
les restaurants comme ça c'est pas de
l'astrolabe grands événements et
d'installer des petits kiosques pour
permettre aux festivaliers d'aller se
restaurer à c'est une partie de
plaisance potter des taxis des
chauffeurs des taxis de pouvoir se faire
aussi des contenus pouvant se faire
remonter leurs économies à travers le
transport des festivaliers de quartier à
un autre ou même aller visiter la ville
d'abidjan
aussi au-delà du transport on a les
individus qui l'intérêt donne une
occasion de monter le chiffre d'affaires
est en hébergeant des touristes des
festivaliers et aussi c'est une
opportunité pour le journal c'est aussi
d'avoir du contenu culturel d'avoir du
contenu en terme d'émissions pour nos
programmes à 12 ans au delà des
retombées en vue oui à les initier ou
des retombées financières
je pense que c'est à pouvoir augmenter
puis ça bouge
les répondants culturel et retombe au
plan diplomatique et les échanges
aujourd'hui je parie que l' échange
entre le canada et la côte d'ivoire a
permis culture a permis aux ivoiriens de
mieux connaître les canadiens du mieux
connaître la culture canadienne parce
qu'à travers les arts à travers les
poèmes à travers les slameurs à travers
toute cette diversité culturelle du
canada qui se paie porte ici à abidjan
c'est un plus pour la population c'est
un plus pour le côté politique de côté
du culturel site b merci beaucoup pour
ce rapport très culturelle est très
informatif merci beaucoup
puis on vous souhaite bonne continuité
n'hésitez jamais à communiquer avec nous
oubliez les gouvernements appelez-nous
directement c'est quelque chose qui se
passe dans ce qu'est vraiment merci
merci à vous a déplu montréal je termine
en disant comme ça il va penser de simon
gorecki du bo qui disait la jeunesse à
rêver et si on les empêche de rêver ils
vont nous empêcher aussi les deux remis
d'ici là qui est bien dit ces idées de
maféré journée ce producteur radio là
bas pour radio mauzé que je surnomme
entendu parler inspirant on est bien
content d'avoir vu l'émission avec vous
relaver quelqu'un qui est vous prêt pour
la devinette de la sema n'y a pas
d'interdît que c'est fini c'est l'image
de la semaine
oui deviner quelle est l'image de la
semaine où la peur la femme du premier
canadien je vous dirais que si c'était
au canada ce serait peut-être la semaine
ne se passe aux etats unis c'est asus se
passerait peut-être s'est adressé à la
nation
non
3 quel joueur s'en passer des choses
gaubert communiqué du chef des mickeys
j'avais mis de les séparer française
gaubert pas quelque chose
jobin les français je sais pas trop
toujours est il qu'il a été touché par
un logo
bah oui c'est sûr merci oui c'est
évident voici l'image donc et on a pris
plusieurs images de l'image voilà qui
arrive à la conférence de presse et
éventuellement il va se moquer d'eux en
fait il ay là je crois qu'il a minimisé
l'impact du convive 19 il a été pris au
piège que rudy gobert
c'est à ce qu'ils aient un an continue
lui parler dans les médias c'est
toujours plaisant et non on lui souhaite
un prompt rétablissement
c'est pas drôle du tout un regard dont
il a voulu faire une blague
sauf que son équipe il revient vers les
micros d'origine de très mauvais goût
voilà webactu à l'epci n'étaient pas des
malades seraient tous deux l'intention
était de faire rire ouais le monde sauf
qui me servait le problème c'est que les
gens comme ça qui font des trucs comme
ça c'est qu'après ils avouent qu'ils ne
connaissent pas grand chose à propos de
la maladie quoi le 19
et pourtant il ya plein d'informations
qu'on peut trouver autant sur le site de
l'om est ce vrai autant sur les sites
gouvernementaux
on explique bien avec des questions clés
c'est vrai que c'est important
s'informer c'est important d'être fait
d'accord avec les deux principes mais se
dévoue aux pourparlers de haut débit les
missions de la panique et moi je j'ai
une amie qui passent du temps beaucoup à
regarder la télévision
moi j'ai pas tout à fait le temps parce
que j'ai des choses à faire preuve
personne aime beaucoup de bonnes choses
en ce moment mais elle passe beaucoup
d'intelligence je le remarque le ton
monte je remarquai ça ces jours derniers
et puis je me dis que peut-être le
conseil que l'on peut se donner à tous
pour diminuer la pression pression tout
en restant ouvert à la possibilité qu'il
existe un danger c'est de fermer tout en
s'informant c'est de fermer la
télévision la radio
peut-être quelques-uns peut-être une ou
deux jours un ou deux jours c'est pas à
moi de vous dire combien de temps c'est
à vous de savoir que ça fonctionne moi
je sais que ça peut fonctionner
mon corps et garder un certain sens de
l'humour face à tout ça tout à fait mais
je pense pas que ce soit une bonne idée
de fermer la vanne à la télévision parce
qu'il ya des mises à jour sur une base
quotidienne
ok on a le poids du québec qui a privé
avec sa panoplie de mesures
oui à vider les épisodes aujourd'hui
encore je crois qu'il y aura de
nouvelles directives que va donner
donc je pense pas que ce soit une
excellente idée de se couper comme ça de
l'information d'accord c'est votre
c'est mon opinion enfin et vous la part
des fois il faut c'est vrai une autre
forme et c'est très bon voilà je dois
encore lego moi je dirais s'informer
mais sans s'énerver dans ces énergies
ont paniqué autant que d'accord on y va
pour ça ok il est gentil ce qu'est ce
qu'ils font rue pasteur enfin continuer
à réformer c'est de vérifier et de
donner la bonne information et à leurs
justes dans la population qui a vraiment
besoin d'être bien et fort ok peut-être
que d'expliquer cinq choses en même
temps d'expliquer une à la fois mis à la
fois tout à fait oui parce que ce n'est
qu'on sait que je vais moi même essayé
de suivre
merci d'avoir été là à l'émission
aujourd'hui et j'espère que vous
appréciez le temps mina may s'est pas
toujours facile dans deux cas dans des
cas on aborde souvent des causes des
questions de sociétal difficile cette
émission toujours sur la forme du jeu et
du plaisir puisque après tout la vie ce
n'est pas qu'un drame
c'est aussi une occasion de fêter
ensemble à la semaine prochaine
notamment
[Musique]